okay good morning everybody or good
afternoon if you're on the East Coast
this is Michelle done I'm in the office
of the Associate Director for data
science and I'd like to welcome you to
this webinar the bd2k guide to the
fundamentals of data science this is the
one that's sandwiched between two
holidays so we were off last week for
Veterans Day we'll be off next week for
Thanksgiving but we have a great talk
today and it's actually part one of a
two part series on data wrangling we
thought that data wrangling was such a
complex topic that it warranted and it
really needed to two examples so we have
one today on a eg and the next time we
meet the week after next so the week
after Thanksgiving will we'll have
another data wrangling talk that focuses
on text mining so two very different
examples I'd like to mention that this
session it's like all the others is
being recorded and you can find it at
the big data you website afterwards we
will have time most likely we'll have a
few minutes at the end for questions and
you can put those questions in the chat
box during the talk or as soon as it's
done and we'll take a few of the
questions from there so it gives me
great pleasure to introduce today dr.
Joseph Kony he is currently a professor
in the Department of Electrical and
Computer Engineering at Temple
University he received a PhD in
electrical engineering from Illinois
Institute of Technology and has since
had a variety of research experiences
spending significant portions of his
career in academia in industry and in
government his primary research
interests are in machine learning
approaches to acoustic modeling and
speech recognition so recently he is
has also been focusing on
commercializing technology in order to
automatically interpret luigi's dr.
Bocconi is a member of the I Triple E he
has authored numerous papers in machine
learning and holds several patents as
well he's and then finally he's copy I
on an NIH bd2k grant titled automatic
discovery and processing of EEG cohorts
from clinical records so that grant of
the collaboration between Temple
University and UT Dallas so with that
I'd like to turn it over to dr. pukani
and and first of all and thank you very
much for coming to give us this lecture
today I'm really looking forward to it
great ok well good good morning or
afternoon we're really excited to have a
chance to talk data wrangling to people
today and really appreciate him the
hosting the seminar so we can get a
chance to have this meeting what I would
like to do today is to talk mostly about
how important data wrangling is to this
whole area of machine learning and big
data data wrangling is defined as the
process of mapping data from an
unstructured format to another format
that enables automated processing so
that's a pretty vague statement I think
but today what we're going to do is
we're going to focus on data wrangling
of physiological signals because these
posed some rather unique challenges
compared to text data or the other types
of data that you find and in a lot of
machine learning applications signal
data is always a bit more challenging
because of the nature of the signals so
we'll focus today on signal data and
particularly we'll spend some time
talking about EE G's and then the next
talk will focus more on the text side
how we deal with medical reports and how
we deal with unstructured text data
which also plays a role in this because
we need both sources of data to actually
do automated data wrangling of these
types of signals so let's begin then by
talking a little bit about Big Data and
machine learning for many years now
we've had a fairly well-defined
iterative process to developing this
kind of technology which we might call a
classic machine learning learning
paradigm
it begins with collection of data data I
hope if there's one message I'll leave
you with today
it's how important data is to solving
these kinds of problems because if the
data is not representative of the
problem then most of the research done
is really not that valuable and making
the data representative of the problem
is also much more challenging than
people think so we'll talk quite a bit
today about data and the associated
issues with data such as annotation but
we begin with data we typically select
some features and we're always worried
of course about whether these features
capture meaningful differences between
the patterns we then select some model
or we might try many models but we
always worry how do we find the best
model we'll then go through a training
process where we estimate the parameters
of the model and try to optimize the
model on the data and then we'll
evaluate the classifier and if all goes
well that evaluation will give us
insight into the data itself and very
often we end up then recollecting or re
annotating the data and beginning the
process all over again we'll also talk
today a little bit about how important
evaluation metrics are to these problems
and how important it is to make sure
that as you optimize the technology
you're optimizing it on things that are
meaningful to the end users of the
technology but this is sort of a closed
loop process because we can iterate on
this many times and the technology today
is sufficiently powerful enough that if
we're if we train on the same data that
we evaluate on we can usually drive
error rates very close to zero which is
very satisfying but that doesn't mean
that the system necessarily generalizes
well to new data sets so we'll talk a
little bit about
that problem as well other things to
think about often when you do these
kinds of optimizations you end up with
technology which is very application
specific and data dependent what's even
worse though is that customers or users
don't often completely understand the
requirements so very often after you
develop the first version of the system
you find out that that's not really what
the customers wanted and then you
iterate through several times in fact on
EEG data that we'll talk about we're
actually on our fourth generation of
trying to make the system do something
that's relevant to the users and it's
been a learning process for the users as
well as for the technology developers
and data collection is often an ongoing
process that drives a technology in
usually we like to collect data that
allows us to solve specific problems but
you can really can't do that all at once
so every year we try to collect data
that pushes the technology a little
further and we've had an evolution like
that in fields like speech and image
processing we're just beginning that
process in areas like bioengineering
particularly areas like EEG s and such
so why is big data so important I think
many of you have probably seen a lot of
press in recent years about the progress
that's been made on some very visible
tasks such as speech recognition in the
in the past five years alone we've seen
significant improvement in performance
of these systems based on what are
called deep learning systems it's been a
very very exciting very active time
because of this to put this in
perspective on tasks which we were
scoring 80% error rate that's 80% error
rate in the 1990s this is a task based
on conversational speech recognition
today we're forint we're scoring error
rates in the range of about seven
percent the performance on these tasks
is getting very close to human
performance and that didn't happen
overnight however that took about 50
years of research to get to that point
but progress been significant in the
last five years and that's primarily
been due to the emergence learning
systems coupled with the availability of
large amounts of data so this is a slide
I want people to really pay attention to
that deep learning systems require large
amounts of data we can get very good
performance with these systems but we
need lots of data and this is one of a
number of examples that have been cited
in recent years here we have a task
where we compare what was conventional
technology maybe 10 years ago most of
most of commercial systems were based on
a technology called hidden Markov models
and here we have a deep learning system
and on a fairly moderate amount of data
you very often see that these deep
learning systems perform comparable e to
the existing technology but you don't
see big wins with these systems because
these deep learning systems have many
many parameters associated with them and
they take a long time to train on the
data and you just need lots of data
however when we do have lots of data so
when we go from for example about 10
hours of speech data to about 2000 hours
of speech data we begin to see very
significant differences in performance
between the two so that's a good that's
good news in some sense because it says
if we have adequate resources to develop
the technology we can get very very good
performance but this is a very sobering
issue for biomedical or bioengineering
applications because it's very rare that
such applications have the equivalent of
2,000 hours of speech data and I'll talk
a little bit about that in a moment
big data is everywhere
a couple favorite quotes of ours in the
speech research community which I've
worked in for many years we actually
back in the mid 80s a researcher at IBM
Bob Mercer coined a phrase which has
been very popular which is there's no
data like more data with new data you
always learn new things and you always
worry about the Syst the ability of your
system to generalize so it's always good
it never hurts to have more data
more recently you've heard a lot about
big data and here's one of the more
famous quotes about big data there's
everybody talks about it but in reality
when you start looking at the datasets
available in the community for various
bioengineering tests you very often find
that these datasets are small they may
consist of tens of subjects or even a
hundred of subjects but they don't
consist of thousands or tens of
thousands or millions that we need to
train these big data systems and and
that's something that we're attempting
to change there is why are we so
interested in this well there is there's
a belief that if we can actually build
systems that look over large amounts of
data we can develop new science we can
uncover new relationships and
dependencies or we can improve the
ability of systems to diagnose and oh I
want to come back to that issue because
that's an interesting issue when we talk
about areas like EEG s or pathology that
require significant amounts of expertise
so where do we get this kind of data
well in commercially viable applications
there are significant economic
motivation so in an application like
speech recognition where billions of
dollars are being invested in
development of the technology there's a
good justification for creating large
data resources and to some extent since
everybody understands language we all
use it every day the data is quite
abundant in bioengineering applications
however the commercial opportunities are
not so significant it's not to say that
they're not important they're of course
very important but when you start
dealing with financial issues and and
such there's less willingness to invest
the amount large amounts of money in
collection of data so the development of
data resources is lagging however there
is enormous amounts of data available in
the healthcare industry so I'll talk
today about a database we've been
building over the past four years which
is a known as a tuh EEG corpus and it
essentially consists of the last
fourteen years of each
has collected a temple hospital we're
now about 30,000 sessions over 16,000
patients and it's a very rich very
interesting database because it's pure
clinical data it's not collected under
controlled conditions it's very real
data there's a lot of this data if we
count video and such the size of
staggering but we're able to this up we
use about a terabyte worth of disk space
to process the experiments that I'll
talk about a little bit later today if I
take another example we've recently
become interested in digital pathology
every hospital has a Department of
Pathology every department of pathology
reads lots of slides every day we
estimate that there may be as many as 1
million pathology slides read each day
so if there was a way to tap into that
data we could build very very large
databases that would fuel the
development of these deep learning
systems but of course tapping into that
data is a bit of a challenge because of
IRB and HIPAA concerns and that's really
one of the reasons we see data wrangling
become so important there's different
facets of the data wrangling problem but
collect creating a pipeline where the
data from these clinical applications
can flow directly into research is very
important because then very quickly we
can generate the vast amounts of data
that we need to train these systems why
is big data crucial well it's very easy
to take a very large database and filter
through it to find that it's actually
very small so when we look at specific
patient histories even in the EEG corpus
that we collected which is over 16,000
patients when you want look at patients
with specific medical conditions you
start to find out that a very small
number of subjects in the database
actually have those conditions or share
those conditions
so the even though the data starts to be
very large one of the interesting things
about bioengineering applications is
they're the the subjects are so unique
that when you start to do specific
Studies on the data
these large databases begin to look very
small and this is something we're seeing
for example with seizures even though we
have a large number of EEG sessions in
our data the number of sessions in which
patients actually experienced seizures
is not as large as you might think and
is actually on the small side for
developing this kind of technology but
what's more interesting is that
clinicians often see a small percentage
of the total population throughout their
career and a lot of their ability to
read and interpret this data is based on
the patient's that they've seen over the
years and one of the reasons I think big
data is really interesting is very few
clinicians will see the full range of
diseases and pathologies in their
particular discipline they tend to see a
subset that's indicative of the type of
patients that they see and when they
then encounter patients outside of those
norms they also have trouble
interpreting this information so it's
really important that with big data we
can look across large populations and I
think actually build systems that may
ultimately exceed human performance
because they can see a much wider range
of conditions than your average
clinician might see so let's look
specifically at two applications EEG s
e-g s are used to diagnose a variety of
brain related illnesses and the process
that's done today is actually very
similar to the way that was done 50
years ago an EEG is recorded for a
period of time that can be range from 20
minutes to several days and then a
clinician sits down and reads those EEG
s and looks for evidence of seizures and
things like that I'm about 93% of these
short-term EEG s are inconclusive so
patients often have to come back to the
hospital several times or be under
observation for long periods of time
before neurologists can see the types of
things they need to see to properly
diagnose the patient manual
interpretation of an EEG is performed by
a board-certified neurologist that means
they usually have to de have to go to
school they'll usually do a residency
after that and then they'll often do a
fellowship after that so before they
come board certified you're talking
about many years of training and that's
why there's a shortage of people who can
read and interpret aegs which presents a
great opportunity for automated
technologies like we're discussing today
but ec EEG signals themselves are very
challenging to interpret um neurologists
usually do this by visually inspecting
the waveforms and looking for specific
events that they think are an indication
of abnormalities but not surprisingly
the interrater agreement on these
localized events is actually very poor
they may not catch every event they may
not mark every event certainly their
general there's general agreement on a
diagnosis at a high level they obviously
diagnose the patients properly but at a
low level there's a lot of room for
interpretation of these events and
that's what makes this a very
challenging problem from a machine
learning standpoint is we're actually
trying to replicate the craft that
neurologists use to read these and
interpret these EE G's and it's very
difficult to codify that with algorithms
so deep learning again provides a very
interesting opportunity for us and that
we hope these algorithms are capable of
automatically learning some of this
information from the signal rather than
having to build an expert system that
tries to replicate the way neurologists
actually do this if we look at a similar
application surgical pathology this is
an application that's beginning to pick
up a lot of momentum in the community
because it's viewed as a nice
application of machine learning
technology it's a very big operation
because every Hospital at the surgery
essentially has a pathology lab running
seven by 24
it takes a significant amount of
schooling to be certified to interpret
these pathology slides and therefore
again there's a shortage of people who
can do this the
the benefits of this are obvious we can
we can do remote diagnosis we can do we
can automate this process and handle
things much more efficiently than having
neurologists on call 24 hours a day but
it's also like many of these problems
somewhat subtle there's a large number
of cases you could say there's sort of
textbook ish but it's not uncommon that
a neurologist will call in other
neurologists when they see something
that they're not familiar with because
they or is outside of the norm of what
they're used to seeing on an everyday
basis so what we're going to talk about
next for a few slides is this problem of
real-time automatic interpretation of
EEG so what that means in a nutshell is
you take a signal and you automatically
label it for events which are deemed to
be important by a neurologist so here
we're showing the ability to label
particular channels with events and then
we can also make some kind of summary
judgement about the event and the the
neck types of things you look for can
vary we'll talk a little bit about
seizures and we'll talk a little bit
about signals like spikes real-time
seizure detection is a very big need in
this area because very often patients
will be under observation in an ICU or
an epilepsy Monitoring Unit and they'll
be there for long periods of time and
they'll be under constant observation
but neurologists won't be available to
actually read and interpret the EEG is
in real-time so there's a great
opportunity for real-time detection
because that will allow neurologists to
better treat their patients because
they're getting notified more quickly
when seizure events and things like that
occur but detection of seizures is very
challenging and most of the commercial
technology today false alarms at such a
high rate that neurologists and
clinicians simply turn off the real-time
alerting
and this is a problem that's be gained a
lot of interest in the past few years
because there's so many automated
systems and hospitals producing
real-time alerts and so many of them
false alarm at such a high rate that
physicians and care providers
essentially ignore all of these
real-time alerts so if you can do
seizure detection reliably with the low
false alarm rate that would be a very
significant advance in the field what
things we're trying to do in this
context we're trying to identify the
start and stop time of the signal we're
trying to identify which channels that
occurred on so we can localize that to
the portion of the brain where it's
occurring and then we try to identify
that a few other things like this the
type of seizure that's occurring seizure
detection using surface EEG recordings
is extremely challenging because the
signals are very noisy and real-time
clinical applications demand an
extremely low false alarm rate this is
much below what current machine learning
systems are capable of but ideally they
would like one false alarm every eight
hours which is very very aggressive goal
when we talk about other types of events
that we'd like to automatically label in
a signal here's an example of some of
them spikes and sharp waves G pads plugs
and such we also have a number of
artifacts that we have to be able to
ignore things like eye movements and and
building algorithms to do this requires
the signals be labeled with these kinds
of events but of course if there's poor
integrator agreement amongst experts on
when these notes are that creates a
problem that you don't have the gold
standard annotations of the data that
you need to produce high performance
systems clinical data contains many
artifacts that can be easily interpreted
into spikes this is why false alarm
rates are so high with some of these
systems Emanuel knew the data is time
consuming and in ICU applications the
need to analyze this data in real time
is where important performance
requirements for this application
ideally would be detection rates above
90% 95% and false alarm rates below 5%
and we do have technology which is
approaching those levels of performance
now that's one of the things we've been
able to build over the past few years so
we think the technology is getting to
the point where it's clinically relevant
so how do we do this while most machine
learning systems go through a fairly
standard process of converting the
signal to some kind of feature
description we then take the and spot
use those that system then to spot we do
a first passive decoding little spot
events then we apply a second pass of
decoding which attempts to look at
sequences of those events and throw out
the outliers do a little bit of
smoothing a little bit of
post-processing and then we do a third
level of post-processing sometimes these
two levels are combined but the general
idea is you take these raw outputs and
you try to post-process them with a
system that's capable of understanding
the context in which these events occur
and interpreting them more accurately so
the current system that we've developed
which operate close to human performance
on this test with a mixture of hidden
Markov models and deep learning we're in
the process of replacing the hidden
Markov model portion of that with a deep
learning component generally speaking of
the size data sets that we have the
performance differences between most of
these different types of machine
learning systems is pretty small and it
really is more a function of the
definition of the problem itself and how
the data is annotated in terms of the
performance that you measure arguing
about what's what's not a seizure what's
an important irrelevant Caesar and so
forth so let's now begin to talk a
little bit about data wrangling so we
want to build a system that's able to do
this and in a perfect world we would
have data that was annotated very fine
level so that we could build what are
called supervised machine learning
systems systems
learn data to the answers that you want
and you've got very high quality
annotations that allow you to do that
unfortunately there's a whole slew of
news with this kind of data that have to
be dealt with before you can get to that
point so the easy stuff of so we like to
stay sort of this stuff first and
foremost we have an anonymous Asian
issue as many of you probably know in
dealing with healthcare related data you
have to preserve the anonymity to
patients and such with some data that's
relatively simple you can with text data
for example you can remove patients
names and patient information if the
data structured and things like that
with some data that's very difficult we
have for example videos of patients
which while they're under well their EMU
or ICU under observation with EEG s in
addition to collecting the EGS they also
collect video well we can't really
anonymizing the videos be very expensive
and therefore we can't really release
the video yet we know that neurologists
use both video use signals to determine
if it's having a seizure but
anonymization of the video is virtually
impossible anonymization of the signal
data is not so bad we can develop
scripts to and and processing systems to
do that but it's also time consuming it
with our EEG data for example we've had
to manually go through in every EEG
report and remove names and things like
that so that the data is anonymous and
that that's a very time-consuming
process we can some of it in an
automated way with natural language
processing but just to be on the safe
side we've X we have to manually remove
every piece of text data before it's
released into the public domain but
that's sort of it I would say in a
scheme of things are relatively easy
part of the problem then it gets a
little more interesting when you talk
about the signal data itself so EU G's
are a multi-channel signal electrodes
are placed
around the head and you collect the
electrical signals associated with these
electrodes but of course there's not a
single configuration that people use and
there's not a single way in which that
configuration is administered there's
actually several ways in which they
administer aegs including what they use
is a reference point for voltages
whether they difference signals go forth
neurologists when they view the data
prefer to view the data in a
differential mode where they subtract
the voltage is collected from two
channels and there are several montages
which are popular one of the ones that
they like to use for seizures is a
montage from all the TCP montage so in
addition to the raw data they will often
not view the raw data directly but
they'll view different channel
differences of the channels and there's
lots of hearing these things even
something simple like the channel labels
are not standard across institutions so
it's very difficult sometimes to even
tell which channel corresponds to which
electrode and that can vary from
technician that can vary by the hospital
and any kind of automated data wrangling
process has to somehow comprehend that
the channel identity is important
because it does allow us to spatially
localized events so the technology needs
to be robust to all these types of
operational variations and we can do
some things to do to automate this and
we're having some success for example at
operating without the need to use a
montage we can do some of the filtering
and such fairly automatically we can
pair up channels fairly well but very
often the the referent the reference
voltage reference points used to collect
EEG those play a pretty significant role
in the data itself and and that's a
little bit hard to adapt to
automatically so another solution is to
build models for each of these
these configurations that you expect to
see and that's often what a lot of the
commercial providers do is they they
just have systems that are tuned to the
particular configurations that their
customers are using and then there's
also artifact removal there's a lot of
different artifacts that occur because
these signals are so low in voltage and
they're so sensitive you often get a lot
of artifacts in the data whether that's
due to things like patient movements or
or electrical issues like grounding and
such or electrical issues like 60 cycle
noise and things you have to remove all
of these otherwise your algorithms are
going to false alarm on the on these
events and call them seizure type events
so there's a fair amount of
pre-processing that goes into the data
and that's often done through a mixture
of filtering and in some cases more
sophisticated noise reduction signal
processing we actually build specific
models of these events such as eye
movements and things and as part of the
pattern recognition process we identify
those as eye movements and then we can
were able to ignore them that's a much
better strategy than trying to build
more classic systems that try to filter
these signals or try to operate on the
waveforms with some kind of heuristics
to remove these types of artifacts but
most commercial systems do a fair amount
of artifact removal and the neurologists
do rely on that to be done before they
begin to interpret the EEG s so let's
next talk a little bit about feature
selection most EEG s are analyzed based
on waveforms but there has been a
growing use of frequency domain
visualizations in recent years in areas
like speech recognition we've used
frequency domain representations for
many many years back going back all the
way to the 1950s and 60s it's
interesting that it's just beginning to
appear in the EEG community so here I'm
showing a
actually the onset of a stroke and we
have the waveforms as well as the
frequency domain representations of that
and you if you look closely enough at
the spectra you can be you can see the
EEG is emerging in areas emerging in the
signal about here so one when you're
developing features one of the first
things you have to ask is where does the
information manifest itself and in the
early days of digital signal processing
we would spend a lot of time trying to
develop algorithms that focused on the
specific areas of this time domain
signal or the frequency domain signals
to extract the kind of information we
thought was relevant in this process so
for example in speech recognition
systems and in in image recognition
systems we use a combination of
frequency domain features and time
domain features in speech recognition
for many years we we used a what's known
as a filter Bank approach based on some
kestrel features and we also threw in
time domain energy and then we took
those features and differentiated them
twice had built a fairly large feature
vector that contained estimates of the
time to make Bignell estimates of the
frequency domain signal and derivatives
and so forth in EE G's we actually can
do something similar we actually use a
very similar filter Bank approach with
EEG s because we know that different
frequency ranges correspond to different
activities in the brain and we actually
use a front-end that's very similar to
what we used in speech recognition based
on cultural features and filter banks
but deep learning systems are
increasingly performing this kind of
analysis within the neural network
framework itself and this has been one
of the more exciting aspects of this
research is that we now have deep
learning systems that take as input
samples of the signal or pixel values
from the images and the feature
extraction process is actually being
done inside the deep learning system
so this is a process which is known as a
stacked auto-encoder
there's of course several variants of
these but the idea is that we use a
hierarchy of artificial neural networks
and these networks are trained on the
data so that they learn features that
are very specific to the data and they
actually learn that you could say in a
sense they optimize the features an
advantage of this approach is that the
features are optimized as part of the
training process so I don't have to
invent or deduce some kind of
mathematical mapping of the signal to
features the system actually learns as
part of the training process the optimal
way to do that in fact the system can
learn how to both represent and
discriminate with the features you you
can do for example discriminative
training of features it's a natural part
of how we do this inside of a deep
learning system the learning process is
also unsupervised so we don't
necessarily need annotated data for this
so we can process large amounts of data
through this process and we can arrive
at features which work pretty well
pretty well across large populations and
we really didn't have to do any manual
manual interpretation of the data this
can all be done in an automatic way so
you can transfer this kind of a concept
from domain to domain or application to
application without the need for a lot
of expert knowledge on those specific
specific signals so this is a really
good thing from an automated data
wrangling point of view because I don't
need to have expertise in each
discipline that I'm trying to use this
kind of modeling technology for so the
feature extraction is is certainly one
of the problems that is fairly well in
hand with this kind of technology now as
I mentioned at the beginning of the talk
one of the things that's really happened
in in the field and in recent years is
that these deep so-called deep learning
approaches have been really making vast
inroads in terms of providing
state-of-the-art performance deep neural
works are essentially similar in concept
to the neural networks that were used
many many years ago but they have many
more layers and they have many more
nodes the architectures themselves have
been slowly evolving now that we have
the ability to train and develop these
systems so one particular network that's
very popular these days is the
bi-directional long short term memory
nuts or BL STM as they're called and
this is one of the networks that seems
to be delivering state-of-the-art
performance
there's many proposed architectures for
these systems they're probably easily 50
popular architectures out there today
and each one seems to work well on a
specific set of applications but the one
that works best seems to for a
particular application seems to be very
application dependent though BLS TM seem
to be working well across speech and
video and a few other types of signals
like that these systems contain many
levels in many nodes we're talking about
millions of parameters milk tens of
millions of degrees of freedom and that
is one of the reasons why we need large
amounts of data to train these systems
because they're very very large in terms
of the parameter counts for many years
we envision these systems but we really
did could not get them to train properly
and that was a has been a significant
obstacle until about 2005 in the past
decade or so techniques emerged that
allowed these networks to be trained
these deep networks to be trained
properly and to reach good solutions and
that's really when deep learning started
to take off about the mid 2000s training
techniques began to emerge that allowed
these deep networks to actually converge
to proper solutions we use in training
these systems an iterative or gradient
descent approach so these systems will
typically be trained through thousands
of iterations and that's a very
computationally expensive process and
even since these systems have so many
degrees of freedom they need large
amounts of data
otherwise they have a tendency to over
train so on small data sets these kinds
of very complex systems can give very
very good performance but they may not
generalize well to data that the system
has never seen before the advantage of
course is that you're self organizing
the data using these kinds of approaches
so you can there's a potential for new
scientific insights based on what these
networks are actually learning the
disadvantage though of these deep
networks is that they're computationally
very intensive and they require highly
optimized code and often special
processors to be practical for even
medium sized data sets so when we you
want to train one of these systems on
for example the thousands of hours of
speech data that I referred to earlier
these systems can require thousands of
processors and can run for days at a
time to train so the other I think piece
of the story with deep learning is we
finally have vast computational power
that's inexpensive enough that lots of
researchers have access to it and that's
really allowed the field to take off the
the use of special processors such as
GPUs has made these systems
computationally feasible and that's one
of the reasons why you see so much work
in this area now finally the compute
resources are available so that these
systems can be applied without having to
have a supercomputer but through this
process we I want to come back to this
issue of annotation of data unsupervised
training is really critical in this
field because you don't really have data
which is annotated the way you would
really like if the world were perfect
we'd have lots of EEG data annotated at
the event level localized in time but we
never really have that all that we
actually have is a report and I'm
showing an example of a report here
these reports are essentially
unstructured text even in today's EMR
electronic medical record systems a lot
of the data is still unstructured and
the language that's used is indirect and
purposefully defensive so they will say
things like show
indications of rather than stating
clearly yes or no patient has a
particular syndrome so the report
structure has evolved over time our data
that was collected over 14 years has at
least six different formats for these
reports and the temporal events you'll
notice are not annotated or localized in
fact in these reports when they say
there is a ten Hertz alpha rhythm that's
actually not quite accurate if you
actually measure the frequency of the
rhythm it will be different than that
this is a observation they make based on
a very crude temporal measurement of the
signals so even when they provide
numerical data in these reports there's
a good chance that the data is not
actually accurate
so fully supervised training is not
possible because we just don't have the
information that we need in these
reports to train the systems this is
another big part of the data wrangling
problem is that you want to be able to
build systems when you don't have large
amounts of annotated data so what we
used in this case is an active learning
approach where we iteratively are able
to learn the structure of the data with
very minimal amounts of annotated data
we start with a small amount of hand
labelled data that usually comes from an
expert and then we bootstrap the process
we take that data we build some models
we process the data we identify data
which we have high confidence in data
which we have low confidence in and then
we adjust the models based on that data
and and go back and retrain and we
iterate so the system gets better and
better at identifying the data that it's
that we have high confidence in but
we're also able to take the data that we
have low confidence in and use that to
adjust the performance of the system by
teaching it to learn more about the data
that it has trouble recognizing
sometimes that's done through a human
intervention sometimes we have to have
an expert review the data and decide
which data is within class in which data
is out of class sometimes we can do that
fully automatically but the
almost all systems have to do some
amount of this if you want to be able to
bootstrap up to the very large amounts
of data that you'd like to process
through the system because the it's rare
that you have thousands of hours or tens
of thousands of hours of data that's
fully annotated now one other topic I
wanted to briefly mention was that
channel normalization and adaptation are
also things which are important to this
problem some physiological systems like
EEG s are collected under relatively
controlled conditions so you don't have
to worry about the channel or the the
nature of the analog data varying that
much but even within EEG s
depending on the electrodes the
technician the electrical wiring systems
you can see systematic variations in the
data and these kinds of variations are
very damaging to statistical learning
systems so we have adaptation approaches
that can do this type of channel
normalization and adaptation and we do
make use of those so that we can
automatically ingest data from and be
able to process it in a common framework
and we do that actually today we do that
using a same type of deep learning
approach that we use for classification
we're learning a mapping of the signals
from these different recording
environments we're able to map them into
such a way that they can be directly
compared and that's another example of a
data ringing wrangling problem that's
very challenging is you have to be able
to normalize your data so that it all
can be evaluated in a common framework
so in summary big data can be
transformative there's many areas of
bioengineering where we have somewhat of
an artisan mentality we have experts who
have been trained by practice and they
view their craft as being important
because they've spent many years
acquiring this expertise but we believe
that we can improve on this by in
providing the kind of input we can
generate from these statistical modeling
systems we can also personalize patient
care we can also
form patients and healthcare providers
with best practices which are validated
over worldwide data resources that's
something that's not happening in many
areas of Medicine right now we can also
impact training and certification
because we can provide students with
searchable archives of data deep
learning can play an important role in
this but of course data wrangling
becomes critical because that's the only
way we can create the large data sets
that are needed to be able to train and
develop these large models and robust
parsing of unstructured data is critical
as I mentioned since of diagnosis and
reports are largely entered as
unstructured text so the companion talk
that will be on December 2nd is going to
deal with natural language processing of
these medical reports and how we
actually are able to bring structure to
these reports so that we can use it to
inform the training process but
ultimately even when you develop these
kinds of systems it's really important
that the technology positively impacts
quality of care efficacy and costs so we
still have to spend a lot of time
working with healthcare providers to
understand how they actually make
decisions and how they use this
technology and making those decisions
and that's still a very important piece
of this as I mentioned with our EEG
project we're now in our fourth
generation of what we thought
neurologists need in terms of a decision
support tool and I think now we're
getting on to something which is really
useful but it was very hard to initially
talk to them and get that information it
required working closely with them over
a long period of time trying to
understand exactly how they do their
work and what the gaps were and what the
technology gaps were in that work so
with that I think I'll open the floor to
questions
so dr. bikuni thank you so much for such
a clear and wonderful talk which was
incredibly informative we do have quite
a few questions already that have come
in the first one that I want to pose to
you is about how might a patient donate
EEG data it's your database but more
generally what
what difficulties if any may arise from
bringing in data from other sources
whether it's donated from across the
country or whether you're bringing in a
nother set from a wholesale from another
hospital system yes I have the same
questions so we've been trying to get
hold of data for EEG s and that's been a
very interesting process because a lot
of institutions are very protective of
their data for a variety of reasons
including HIPAA type issues we are in
the process of actually building a
seizure detection subset of this data
that's going to be annotated by multiple
neurologists and is going to include
data from multiple sites so we're going
to be able to answer those questions in
a much more detailed way probably within
about three to four months we believe a
signal like EEG from what I've seen it's
collected under fairly controlled
conditions and most hospitals use one of
two systems so there's not a lot of
variation and the way the state is
collected but with other types of
applications like digital pathology for
example there's a big variation and the
way slides are prepared and digitized
and that's one of the reasons we want to
work in that area next we really want to
understand how we can do data wrangling
when the data is much more variable from
hospital to hospital so it sounds like
there are a lot of challenges there so
the next questions are about deep
learning in particular let me start with
the one the more general ones how would
you define or characterize deep learning
machine learning systems and contrast
them with other types of machine
learning apart from their need for big
data so there are I think if we look at
the if we look at the space of machine
learning there are of course parametric
models nonparametric models there are
models that have small number of
parameters and there's models they have
large number of parameters I would tend
deep learning system systems that are
architected as directed graphs of very
simple computational units so those
units could be simple things like a
weighted sum of its inputs followed by
some kind of non-linearity that's the
normal the classic artificial neural
network but you have lots of these very
simple notes so in the past with neural
networks in particular when we had three
layer networks those were considered
those are fairly well-known and those
were existed before deep learning two
took when people talk about deep
learning today they're talking about
networks that have far more than three
layers and have millions of parameters
associated with them and I think that's
the big distinction we had what we
called multi-layer perceptrons many
years ago but they were simply three
layer networks totally general and what
they could learn but they were not as
many levels or as deep vertically so to
speak as the systems that are being
trained today and I also just want to
add to the UM person who asked the
question of that in January
well no not generally but uhm after the
new year or so maybe more like February
we'll have a couple of talks on machine
learning in general to kind of lay out
that big picture of machine learning
with the supervised and unsupervised
learning and classification and the and
regression type problems so you will see
this again it's and more in a machine
learning more holistically later on
excellent yeah excellent
another question is about the the the
mechanics of the deep warning and the
questioner asks about how sensitive the
gradient descent is to the initial
starting point but in addition how
sensitive is it to the different
variations
of gradient descents that are out there
you know they're all different types of
optimization we could be using some of
which are small tweaks some of which are
are more come are even more different
but you know how sensitive is it to to
all those different choices that could
be made in order to 50-point a model
very very good question
and I'll start with the general comment
which is that if you you don't just pick
up a toolkit off the net and implement
deep learning and get state-of-the-art
performance the reality is there's a lot
of heuristics a lot of anecdotal
information a lot of tweaking that goes
on for these state-of-the-art systems to
deliver the performance that they do we
most of our work is based on a open
source toolkit Theano for example and we
can run a lot of the packages built
within that tool and these packages tend
to perform comparably on the data that
we have but once you start getting deep
into the research and tweaking them you
can make them do a little bit better
with regard to gradient descent and type
I I was formerly of the impression that
there wasn't much difference we had seen
comparable performance across a lot of
different configurations but recently
with these LS TM networks we've been
seeing some a significant improvement in
performance using a particular set of
training techniques and I can talk
offline about what those are but
generally you're talking about a 10%
relative reduction in error right so our
system goes from about 70 percent error
to 80 70 percent accuracy to 80 percent
accuracy using what you might say our
best practices in terms of training that
is in some ways you could say
substantial but the problem with both
those systems is the false alarm rate is
still 2 orders of magnitude higher than
it needs to be so that's sort of in the
noise compared to the problem we have
with false alarm rates ok but but still
some improvements better than nothing so
nothing and the science in this area is
getting much better but it really
there's old still a lot of artists
associated with training these deep
learning systems yes and so that's why
we need experts to to do this and to
help with this and by the way if anybody
wants to contact us we'll be happy to
share everything we're doing and and
help you you know bring you up to speed
on what we think works well for these
kinds of signals it thank you I'm sure
people will take you up on that so there
is a question about that let me just ask
it do you see your model and algorithms
being used in other fields I also was
thinking about this as you were talking
because I find it very interesting how
you take how you took the state of the
art from the speech community and
brought in the ideas about using the
frequency domain in addition to their
time domain and implied them in
biomedical science and I was wondering
you know how do you see what you're
doing now in the eg biomedical science
world do you see any of that being
translated back into other domains like
a more general speech recognition I
would hope so we did some work on
nonparametric Bayesian models that has
been cross fertilizing both domains but
I think the I'd like to say yes the the
problem is the the amount of investment
in areas like speech and image is so
great and you've got some of the best
groups in the world putting tremendous
amounts of resources and those problems
so it's been a little bit difficult to
keep up with that in a smaller area like
EEG processing but that the techniques
were using on Eng are informed by speech
and image recognition so there's no
reason it couldn't go the other way that
we try not to develop techniques that
are specific to one application and
that's why for example we're going to
take the same technology and apply it to
digital pathology and I think that we'll
have some success there as well well
it's very exciting in a very exciting
area we do really look forward to your
the the follow-on talk in a couple weeks
I just wanted to I think we should
go ahead and wrap it up today and let
everyone know that we can talk more
about it in two weeks from now after
Thanksgiving so dr. Marconi I want to
thank you so much for for taking the
time today to tell us about this work
and to tell us about data wrangling and
it give us a big picture of it and I
really look forward to hearing your
colleagues speak about the text mining
in two weeks so thank you and thank you
everybody for joining us today
bye-bye thank you